[Music]
all right so hey everybody uh it's me uh
Josh again and today we're going to be
looking at a couple of cases of good
preparation uh playing White against
French winnower so the games we're going
to be looking at today are all involving
uh preparation uh prepared by me
personally doesn't mean that I played
all the games but yeah so let's get
started so uh to start off with so
French when we're evolving uh French
with Knight C3 Bishop B4 so this is a
very uh combative opening so uh a big
part of Black's strategy here is black
is announcing the desire to part with
the bishop pair and in the way of Bishop
takes C3 which removes the dark Square
Bishop for black
um
and which therefore uh creates a lot of
positionally undesirable situations for
black but the double pawns on C3 are the
black's compensation so after Bishop B4
so the most aggressive and principled
move
um it was just favored by myself is the
movie E5
so the first game we're going to be
looking at today where I'm playing White
against uh Carlos Antonio heavy Aliano
um a uh a grand master and this was
played in the Pan American
Intercollegiate Championship so this
would have been a online rapid game for
the Pan-American match between Berkeley
and I want to say uh
utrgv I don't remember
um
anyway so in this position uh there are
a couple of moves we're going to look at
some games following the main move C5
which today we're going to be uh but for
to start off with we're going to be
looking at the move Queen D7 which is a
little bit of a rare move so Queen D7
looks incredibly bizarre
um I mean it certainly does to me at
least so okay so first of all we
understand that with the move E5 white
has closed the center which means that
black can afford some time to do things
so first of all let's take a look at
what happens after B6 which is the most
uh or should I shouldn't say the most
common move but it's also a very common
move to play B6 in this position with
the simple idea of playing Bishop A6 and
exchanging some light Square Bishops so
this plan is pretty effective against
this Pawn structure but after the queen
G4 we can see the big drawback of the
bishop B4 black will end up having to
make a concession to protect the G7 pawn
and in this position in fact Black's
most common move is actually Bishop f8
again it looks really crazy but because
the center is closed black doesn't lose
too much from doing this but so the idea
of Queen D7 is to prepare uh the move B6
and meet Queen G4 with F5 to protect the
G7 Pawn from uh from laterally and the
Queen on D7 does not really get in the
way of Black's pieces since the bishop
is not particularly going in this
direction anyway
so after Queen D7
um so Queen G4 right now is no longer
super effective because after F5 we
don't really want to be taking on F6
since black is going to be developing
with Tempo and uh if we Retreat the
queen then G7 is protected and black
just continues with the normal plan
so there is an another way in this
position to directly Target Black's dark
scroll weaknesses that have been created
by the Excursion of this bishop on B4
and that is through the move H4
so it looks very weird but this move is
very fashionable in many other lines of
the winner the idea is uh fairly simple
to just simply March the pawn to H6
since the H6 Square since the black
Bishop does not control this square at
the moment
so black should continue the plan of B6
H5 and so H6 here is most natural for
black to hold the H5 Pawn in place black
would definitely not want to sorry black
would definitely not want to meet H6
with G6 and thereby create more
weaknesses on the dark squares
but now we can see the secondary purpose
of H5 so now in the case of Queen G4 on
F5 it is now possible for white to bring
the queen to G6 with check and the
inclusion of the moves with h pawns has
been very unfavorable for black in this
Bond structure since the end games that
will result will always end up with a
very powerful white nylon F4 that cannot
be harassed by any Pawns
so in this position the historically
most common move has been Bishop f8 and
so this has actually been a well-known
position for for a while usually not
through this through this exact move
order
um but this is a position that that has
been known for quite some time and there
have been uh I believe around 30 games
in the database over the last uh 10 20
years something like this
and uh this this position is is
generally regarded in the past as being
slightly better for white but it was
technically uh very difficult for white
to actually execute a plan here so the
Practical results have been much better
for black than the engine evaluation
would suggest for example Alexander
Lenderman in the year where he won the
U.S Championship uh sorry U.S open sorry
um actually managed to reach a really
fascinating position against a much
weaker player who played Bishop E3 in
this position which should also tightly
lead to some Advantage but in this
position I had done some digging and so
I had realized that uh there is a
different way for white to play so in
this position black has two primary
ideas so uh
what are some of those ideas so one of
the ideas we talked about before black
wants to exchange the lights for Bishop
and play Bishop A6
um with the exchange of light Square
Bishops which is very favorable to Black
in this Pawn structure
um
the other one is that since there is a
pawn in B6 black can play C5 and
recapture on C5 with the B Pawn which is
very positionally desirable so C5 would
also be a good plan for black but there
is one move here for white that looks
very shocking that is able to
address both of these concerns at the
same time
it is
one of the moves that I'm very proud of
finding not over the board of course
because even if you see it's possible
you would need some serious stones to
actually pull this off but the best move
in this position which already confers a
nearly winning advantage in this
theoretical position is the move B4
so what is the point of B4 so first of
all when someone plays B4 you need to
check whether Bishop takes B4 is
possible and so it turns out that it is
not since Queen takes G7 is the much
more serious threat and after Bishop
takes C3 both Bishop D2 and King D1 lead
to a winning position after Queen takes
h8 as black is not able to hold the
Knight on G8 thanks to King f8 Bishop
takes H6 check and so black is going to
end up being crushed in a winning attack
more or less so
in this position and Black's other uh
ideas don't work as well either because
Bishop A6 can now simply be met like B5
and uh the the problem for black here
for something Bishop D2 uh it's not
specifically necessary the this exact
move
um but uh the problem for black is that
the bishop is now very bad on B7 it
doesn't really have anywhere to go so
far in the future so
Bishop A6 is no longer as affected and
on C5 white is simply going to capture
and the opening of the B file is
extremely uncomfortable for black so
something like this would be uh very
dangerous with Rook B1 coming soon so
this movie B4 restricts all the blacks
uh
desirable Pawn breakthroughs or just
positional ideas in general and so what
black is supposed to play here is black
should play F5 but this is a very very
unpleasant end game for black
um the what again the White Knight is
going to come to F4 Rook B1 I believe is
imprecise because of Knight C6 with a
double attack on the pawns here but A3
has the same purpose and the general
premise here is that this end game is
really difficult for blacks and C5 is
never going to be possible and white can
develop the knights to these great
squares on F3 and F4
so in the game uh have you decided to
play A6 so this move doesn't really have
a specific idea but it's simply a
prophylaxis preparing C5 without being
worried about Bishop B5 in the future
so after A6
um
so I played A3 which is not the best
move um I think it's a little bit better
to just play Rook B1 since it's very
difficult to imagine black can play the
position without C5 what I was worried
about personally was I was just thinking
well okay so I just don't really want to
uh I just really want to like commit my
Rook here since it's not necessarily
true that black is going to play C5 but
without C5 A6 doesn't make a whole lot
of sense so perhaps this is a better
continuation but after A3 we have 97
uh Bishop D3 C5 takes takes takes so the
opening of the position is uh generally
going to be favorable to White here
since white has the much better
developed pieces
so negative three
and the specific moves here don't end up
being too important but essentially
what's going on here is white is
proceeding forward with the better
development and the position is very
difficult for black to play uh heavy
actually came up with a really
interesting idea here to take on D3 and
sacrifice a Pawn on D4 in order to
ensure the activity of the light Square
Bishop along diagonal as well as the D5
Square for the Knight
so uh in this position I decided that it
was the most pertinent plan for me to
start by placing a rook on the C file so
Bishop D2
and we have 95 Queen D4
Bishop B7 but the position remains
incredibly difficult for black so here
we can see another benefit of the early
H Pawn Excursion with Knight H4 and once
the Knight comes to G6 black will not be
able to Castle and so that is very
uncomfortable for black
the game actually ends here with a
really nice combination which is uh
believe it or not in this position I
actually didn't even see that that
worked
um I I got very lucky
um so in this position I played Bishop
before so more or less what was
happening here was so I was hoping for
uh that so Knight takes B4 in this
position is not possible because the
queen takes D7 King takes D7 and Knight
B6 and the fork will be very unpleasant
for black
um
and Bishop takes b4a takes B4 well now
my knight on A4 is protected and I can
jump into C5 or B6 the position is
pretty much lost for black uh this Rook
on Jade is very bad and black has a lot
of trouble getting Castle
so
uh but I actually missed that black
could take an A4 immediately which is
kind of funny and kind of sad and at the
same at the same time so but what I
quickly realized was that the black's
position uh is really uncomfortable
pretty much no matter what so after
Knight takes C7 so black won't be able
to take np4 since a takes B4 will
pressure the black queen and so black is
no time to collect the Knight
um so black is forced to play Knight
takes E7
so in this position I had already seen
that Queen D6 was possible
uh this didn't take me too long to do so
after Queen D7 uh it's already possible
to take on D7 and take on E7 but I felt
that this position would uh not be too
promising for me since black since we do
have opposite colored Bishops on the
board so I thought after Rook 88 or
something like this
um the position would be more or less
salvageable for black
so instead the correct course is to flip
the move order in Rook C7 95 but after
Queen C5 black is losing here so the key
here is that uh whichever piece black
takes on C7 or B4 will allow Queen the
queen to Checkmate on E7 since the
Knight is not able to move in the
meantime black has problems with the
Bichon B7 and the threat of Rook E7
check so in the game have you actually
decided to sacrifice its Queen but
quickly lost on account of the B Pawn
being promoted soon so yeah so here I
think this is a really good point where
we can see the success of white strategy
of playing with the dark Square Bishop
when black has given up theirs so yeah
pretty interesting game I think the main
point here is definitely this move
before
um I believe I am the first to actually
play this so that's pretty good I guess
it's my novelty or something
um where did Black go wrong asks Randy
by Lynn
um
uh I mean pretty much this this whole
opening nowadays is considered to be
borderline refuted because after Bishop
f8 disposition is already lost it's
nearly plus two
um so yeah I guess pretty much the uh
the opening strategy here for black is
just not a successful one so yeah
okay so now we're going to look at some
games in some main lines so uh funnily
enough a lot of these games are actually
uh against the uh same player so let's
go back a bit
all right so this game where I'm playing
White against Indian International
Master uh actually I don't think he was
one at the time but he became one very
shortly after uh better a new dish
speller car
um
so this was actually a tournament where
I made my third Grand Master norm and
therefore completed my Grand Master
title so this was in Hungary the Vedra
kepso tournament in October of 2021.
so basically while preparing for this
guy I had noticed that he pretty much
always plays the French winnower
um which is fine so he mostly plays the
French winner and he was following the
child support course written by Gary
which I also have and I think is a
pretty good course so essentially what I
was looking through was so I looked
through the course and I found some
places where I could look for some
different tries
so let's follow the game the E46
so C5 this is the main line of the
French winner with A3 uh takes takes and
97. so in this position uh the two most
common moves for white are queen G4 and
H4 both of which are attempt to
capitalize on the fact that black does
not have a dark script Bishop nowadays
move H4 is a little bit more fashionable
and people are generally pretty happy to
play this so after Queen C7 H5
so in this position after H6 Rook B1 I
believe napoleonishi was somewhat
successful in the candidates tournament
with the move B6 well candidates of 2020
with the movie B6 but Gary recommends
bc6 as a safer move
so
the idea of Knight bc6 is actually uh
insanely clever and it took me a very
long time to to appreciate this so after
night bc6 so the point is that uh
Afternoon Queen G4
so black would normally have to play a
move like King f8 to protect the G7 Fawn
which is not ideal for black but Gary's
idea is to play Rook G8 in this position
so Rook G8 is normally not considered to
be a great defense to Queen G4 since
after Bishop D3 the threat of Bishop H7
is very uncomfortable for black
because I would force black to part with
either the exchange or the G7 Pawn both
of which being completely disastrous for
black
so in this position after Bishop D3
Geary discovered the amazing idea for
black C4 so it looks very strange to
allow Bishop H7
but there is a beautiful tactical
resource at hand for black beginning
with Knight takes E5
so after Knight takes E5
um so if white immediately takes an E5
after Queen takes the E5 check let's say
92 Rook h8 we can see the purpose of the
move C4 where this white Bishop on H7 is
actually completely trapped and does not
have a way to escape so the position is
not like completely lost for for white
just yet or anything like that white
does have a strong control of the dark
squares but definitely not what white
wants to be doing with being down two
Pawns
so after 9 takes E5 so then the next
immediate response for white would be a
move like Queen G3
so now at blackplayer's Rook h8 then
Queen takes G7 would still be winning
for white with a double attack on the
rook and Knight here
um unfortunately uh black can continue
by trading Queens with mood Knight D3 so
he takes D3 Queen takes D3 and again the
uh Bishop on H7 is trapped and therefore
this position is going to fizzle out to
some equal end game here black has a
couple of ways to equalize I think E5
makes sense as well so yeah so this is
the general idea behind Black's setup
smooth Knight C6
and if you do not play Queen G4 then
black is going to be aiming for a closed
position with long castling which black
is generally fairly comfortable with
so so yes I had gone through the course
and I determined that aphrodite F3
Bishop D7 Bishop E2 castles this is the
one of the main positions in Gary's
course
um and so in this position Geary covers
a bunch of different moves
and the the general consensus is that
black is going to play moves like C4
King B8 Queen A5 and slowly bring the
pieces over to the queen side the
position appears to be roughly balanced
engines will prefer white but in human
play it's a little bit interesting so in
this position what I had thought about
was uh that with white here it makes a
lot of sense to try to play D take C5 so
it looks very odd to play D takes C5 but
there are because there are tripled
pawns but the opening of the position is
what white wishes to achieve with the
bishop pair and the pawn structure is
not so important compared to the
activity of the dark scored Bishop
unfortunately after d takes C5 Knight
takes E5
there is a problem for white in that uh
the natural response Knight takes E5
would be the move Bishop F4 but Knight
takes F3 check is extremely unpleasant
for white being that white will simply
lose a piece due to the discovered check
so white would have to end up taking on
E5 or something but with the triple
pawns here and the good Center for black
it's highly unlikely white is going to
have an advantage in the long run
so an idea I came up with here with the
help of stockfish was the move
King F1
so uh yeah it's very artificial looking
move but it has a couple of key points
so first of all there's no indication
that white really needs to Castle short
or anything like this in this position
anyway being that the center is closed
and there is no particular Danger on the
king side as well as the fact that the
white Rook on H1 can achieve activity
through other ways
but more importantly move King F1
actually threatens D takes C5 so if
black makes some filler move I'm not
sure what that would be maybe uh okay
let's just let's just do a uh a a move
that doesn't do anything let's say Rook
H7 the idea is to threaten D take C5 on
account it might take the E5 Bishop F4
now being possible
so after King F1
um the so the main idea of King F1 is to
chorus black into playing C4 early uh
and then after in this position now that
C4 has been played uh there's a bunch of
ways that are that it's possible to
proceed for white
um
but uh generally speaking C4 will allow
A4 and in this position the white Bishop
is going to be able to go to A3 where it
is optimally placed on this A3 to f8
diagonal
so yeah that's that's the idea of King
F1 it's by threading D takes C5 it's
trying to encourage black to play C4
so in the game we have uh King V8 so uh
King F1 is a novelty at the time and he
hadn't seen it before so he decided to
just play a safe move like King B8
um
so I decided to continue with my plan if
you take C5 which I'm not even sure is
the best route but I felt pretty
comfortable doing it during the game
so the king A8
and Bishop form
so uh so I have achieved my idea of
getting my own tripled pawns but at the
same time Black's position remains
pretty solid and it's going to be it
remains to be seen how white is going to
be concluding the game but a big point
for white is that the move Knight D4 is
going to be pretty strong as the knights
is not harassable here by any pawns
anymore and can potentially enter D6
through B5
so G5 this move is really nice so the
idea is that after H takes G6 Knight
takes G6 the white dark Square Bishop
which was one of the important pieces
for me uh we'll have to go to G3 which
is not an optimal Square since it's very
difficult for it to rejoin the game in
the center from E3 or D2
so Queen A5 was played so black is
actually engaging in a triple attack on
the pawns but the thing is I'm actually
not really too concerned about this so I
decided to continue with Knight D4
yes sorry I meant to ask this a Saturday
I was just thinking about it
um if you go back a few news before G5
yeah what about F6 they're trying to
take advantage of the piano
um so there's a couple of options here
for for uh for white sorry
um so so yeah this is definitely a a
good move uh or a move that is worth
considering for for black
um I think at the very least I can
simply take an F6 and after taking on E7
I take z7 uh I'm going to be of a pawn
here and therefore I'm going to have a
pretty good position uh
so if you wish to save the G7 Pawn you
will probably have to you would probably
take on D4 which I think is
probably very bad after C takes D4 this
is just a pawn right
um so probably black should play
something like Queen F5 but uh I don't
think that I'm really too too worried
about anything here I have pretty solid
control of the E5 square and uh
yeah it looks like I'll be keeping my
extra Pawn
let's answer your question
yeah very much okay good
um but yeah definitely a move that
that's worth considering for black it
just so happens that in this case he
takes F6 as possible
oh yeah it's interesting you mentioned
the thought like I would not have
thought about that because the pawns are
triple
um
but yeah that is yeah yeah I mean I
definitely don't have the have the best
pawn structure but it is a is a
necessary Eagle to generate play in this
position
like in every end game the G6 square is
going to be a big thing right
right yeah I don't really plan on taking
on F6 or anything like this
um probably 95 is is makes a lot of
sense I don't know exactly what what the
best move here is Queen B4 also makes
sense as well since you most likely will
need to play Rook V8 which is a little
bit awkward
um but yeah I mean I'm not really too
too worried here I guess is what I would
say about it okay
um okay so in the game we have G5 takes
Knight takes Bishop G3
and after Queen A5 then comes Knight D4
so in this position I felt pretty
comfortable with where I was at so
um
in the case of so okay so obviously
black is a lot of candidate moves here
there are literally four pawns that
black can take in this position but most
of them have their downsides so for
example Queen takes A3 is meant by
Knight B5
since the obvious move for black queen
takes C5 would end up dropping the queen
to some funny tactics here with Knight
A6 and a fork
so um
so so if this were to happen in
Blackboard to keep the queen in the a
file then black would end up in a pretty
sticky situation uh following the
opening of the a file perhaps Rook A1
immediately is not needed but uh even
just like Knight D6 and the position
seems very difficult for black for sure
um Queen takes C3 is meant very
similarly with Knight B5 Queen takes C5
is not possible due to the same trick
from before so black will have to play
Queen A5 and after Knight D6 there's
actually a fork here on two different
Forks on B7 and F7
uh quintake C5 I thought was possible
but I wasn't really too uh afraid of
this so I believe I would still have
played Knight B5 and the Knight coming
to D6 is very annoying for uh for black
so immediately the threat is Knight C7
so black does not have time to take an
E5 right so
um
so black will have to defend against
this somehow
I'm not entirely sure what the best way
for that to happen would be but here
it's now possible to play F4 and reroute
the bishop to F2 with the tempo and this
position looks pretty good for white to
me
also Knight D6 appears to be possible
again with the fork on B7 and F7
um
so yeah perhaps black already has some
difficulties defending everything in
this position
so in the so that leaves black with two
ways to capture on E5
um and both are completely possible
um in the game black decided to take on
E5 with the c Knight
um
and so then I played the move F4
so in this case after Knight C6 I
believe I would have played
um
Knight B5 and continued with Knight D6
in the future so here I still felt
pretty good about the position
in the case of Knight C4 there is Bishop
takes C4 and black has some trouble
protecting DBC Pawn
um I thought black would probably play
Queen A6 here and I believe this is
actually the best way for black to play
but I wasn't really overly concerned
here I figured at the very least I could
even play something like uh
like Rook B4 and maybe look eventually
for King F2 the truth is that black is
going to play Bishop C6 in the next move
and the position should be roughly equal
but I didn't really feel scared to add
to any point
so
instead the move black played here is
actually a pretty serious blender so
black side the blade Queen takes C3 so
black is understandably very confused
regarding the uh various hanging pawns
and he wasn't really too sure where to
go from here
so Queen takes C3 attacks three pieces
although Knight on D4 is not really
attacked but the double attack on the
Bishops for on C4 and G3 is very
annoying for white
so in the case of Bishop D3 which does
say both the Bishops black is able to
take on D4 and it seems that black is a
great position here because of the
double attack on C5 and F4 winning yet
another Pawn
unfortunately for black the uh Queen the
lineup on the D file is a very standard
theme in the French or really just in
all sorts of openings
and black is not able to recapture the
pawn B7 because of Bishop A6 check
so this would end up winning the queen
here so black is not able to recapture
in B7 and thus the black king is going
to be terribly exposed here
it also turns out in a very unlucky
twist for black that uh
Knight takes I-4 is not possible in
account of Rook B4 with a skewer here
and queen takes C5 is also not possible
on account of another skewer from C5 to
A7
so in the game black decided to go for
Knight E7
um and but after Bishop F2 the position
is pretty much not defensible for black
there are a ton of options here I
thought after Queen takes F4 I believe I
would have played Rook H4 in the game
and even continued to swing more pieces
over to the queen side and I thought the
position was was going to be falling
apart for black in just a couple of
moves
so Queen G7 was played
but after Bishop base6 it turns out that
black doesn't even have a super
convincing way to
defend the
King on A8 so a move like uh
Bishop C8
um it allows Queen B1 and the threats of
Rook B8 and such are decisive so black
doesn't have a great way of removing the
Rook from B7 as Bishop C6 simply drops
the Knight on E7
so black plays rook hg8 in the game
attacking G2 simply defend it with G3
and Knight C6 happens so now in this
position black is sort of threatening
Bishop C8 it doesn't really do a whole
lot but the much more serious threat for
black is the Knight B8 which would uh
severely
destabilize the bishop and Rook on B7 on
A6 and B7 respectively
so uh the best way to get rid of this
was in my opinion not to leave The Rook
on the B file since in this case black
is going to play Rook B8 and I felt that
black was going to be consolidating
since B7 is not uh since I don't really
have a way of attacking V7 any further
but after Rook C7 so now Rook V8 is not
possible since it would drop the bishop
on D7 and Bishop C8 is not possible so
we drop the Knight on C6 so black needs
to come up with a solution for the
threat of Queen B1 which would pretty
much deliver any media Checkmate on V7
so in the game black played Queen B2 but
this allows a different kind of tactic
since after Bishop B7 check and Rook
takes D7 black finds the C6 Knight is
going to be losing its defense and uh
the game the rest of the game from here
turned out to be uh fairly simple
materially black has a rook and a pawn
in exchange for a pair of Bishops but
the problem for black is not so much the
material it's more about the position so
if we just go through a couple of moves
here so the black side to go for some
pretty interesting counter play with
Rook takes G3 but I didn't consider
taking on G3 for more than a a couple of
seconds and because after C6 uh the King
on F1 is extremely safe here and black
is facing down and extremely deadly
attack
and yeah the game ended up being pretty
smooth from this point forward as
there's never really any danger of
Perpetual check
he decided to play Queen H3 for fun at
the end of the game and ended up
resigning there
so yeah this is one of the wins that
helped me to secure my third Grand
Master norm and finish up my title so
yeah that fault's pretty good
um funnily enough I actually played him
the next month in the exact same opening
so uh
so I I didn't uh prepare for it for this
at all
um since I just assumed that he would
play something else as he I think I
think most people if if they lose badly
in one line they're not going to repeat
it but evidently he feels differently so
yeah I guess that's like something that
you need to get used to expecting that
it's uh there are some players who will
just play the same thing no matter what
so in this case he decided to play C4
which is the best move
and here the idea of A4 was executed
um I'm gonna try to go over this game
relatively quickly since uh
um since it is literally the exact same
opening as the previous game and the
same player but I think that it is still
worth looking at some more ideas
essentially the dark Square Bishop on A3
is going to be super powerful uh nadum
on YouTube says Black's position without
dark screen Bishop always feels quite
precarious or impressed by how well some
winter players make it work yeah it's
really interesting
um I think that like this is a really
cool opening if it was if it was even
like one percent easier for black to
play I would probably play this a lot
um but yeah the positions are are just
are are really tough for black in
Practical play
um but yeah there are some players that
uh that like understand the the
positional aspect super well with black
and are able to play around the double
pawns very effectively and like Nicholas
checker for example is a grand master
who is quite an expert on French win
aware and he's very Adept at this type
of position
so we ended up having this in the game
so evidently he is uh pretty comfortable
with a draw here allowing Queen C1 Queen
A5 and a repetition
but I decided to put my queen on A1 and
therefore defend the
A4 Pawn indirectly by way of Queen takes
A4 Bishop D6 check
unfortunately that does not happen after
Knight V6 check King C8
we end up in an incredibly strange
situation after 9684 Rook A2 where black
is playing B5 and I I really had no idea
what to make of this in the game
I mean but I like us up a pond but look
at where the pawn is right the black
king is super weak on C8 and uh I really
wasn't sure what was going on here it
turns out that the position is roughly
equal because black is able to
neutralize the uh the threats on the
queen Side by way of sacrificing a rook
on D6
and
yeah eventually we ended up in an
incredibly strange situation I mean this
is not a pawn structure you see every
day is it with the triple pawns
interspersed by an enemy Pawn somehow
and then a protected pass Pawn on D6 to
follow up so
yeah uh eventually after some mistakes I
was able to place the bishop on H3 it's
very active looking at E6 and the Knight
on a4s immobilized on account of Rook uh
Rook takes A7 So eventually I was able
to bring the queen to D4 and we can see
uh one of the big problems for black
with playing without the dark Square
Bishop is that you need to be very
careful about losses involving the light
Square Bishop since it is since it's a
lack of activity is actually further
magnified by this situation
um yeah So eventually I'm just working
on bringing the Rook to E3 and then
rookie one and now so Rook takes E6 is
not possible on account of Queen takes
G3
so as white in this case you simply need
to retrieve your king and prepare Rook
takes E6 and the position is winning for
white
I thought that was a pretty fun way to
Checkmate
um
although I'm told although if I remember
correctly I think some friends told me I
needed to play C6 because it looks
cooler or something so
yeah
yeah pretty interesting game but
it takes a little bit away from the
focus so what's even funnier about this
is that the next game we're going to
look at is the same player with black uh
dish Butler curve so uh in this case so
this game was played much more recently
this was played November of last year so
just like two or three months ago
it was involving my friend uh Edward
song who's an international master and
he was playing white so I was serving as
his second during this time in Hungary
when he was playing there and so of
course he knew that I had played this
player before and in fact multiple times
and uh so he had asked me to help him
with French winner so we decided to take
a further look at this starting position
so uh definitely I don't want to be we
don't want to be repeating the same
thing over and over again since even if
it is objectively good for white which
it might be
clearly he is already now by now
experienced in the position and it's
something that he would have studied in
detail by now
so we were looking at a couple of
different examples here so we saw one
game that this player with black had uh
played before so we noticed that Arjun
aragi I believe was the player who
played Rook H3 in this position against
him and we thought that was a pretty
interesting line we also thought after
H5 H6 Rook H3 was pretty interesting
essentially this maneuver Rook H3 is uh
is is pretty valuable to protect the
pawn on C3 at some point
but we had what we had settled on was
Rook B1 and then in this position Rook
H3 so a lot of Rook H3 happening
so uh in this position the one of the
normal Maneuvers for black would be uh
Queen A5
um but this is not too effective here
since the Rook is already pressuring H3
so uh sorry pressuring age that's not
what I meant to say since the Rook is
already on H3 and thereby protecting C3
so there are a couple of different
possibilities for black
um
the key idea of this move Rook H3 is a
little bit odd so but so if we remember
correctly after Bishop D3 uh C4 is very
annoying for us since Bishop H7 line
takes D5 and then Queen takes D5 check
allows the bishop on H7 to be trapped
so the move Rook h3s actually serves as
a preparation of Bishop D3 so the key
here is that so if black plays Bishop D7
or something like what happened in the
game the now Bishop D3 is possible since
long castling allows Bishop H7 and the
movement of The Rook will drop the G7
Pawn
in this case Knight takes E5 will no
longer be effective since the Rook on H3
is now present and Rook E3 will allow
white to block the check and achieve a
winning position
uh want to see magic says sorry how does
Knight takes E5 trapped Bishop uh yeah
so we talked about this a little bit
earlier in the in the lecture about the
same position but let's just go over
that again in case anybody missed it so
the idea here is that after Queen takes
the E5 check move like 92 uh just rook
h8 and the bishop on H7 does not have
any Mobility
um if white plays Queen G3 first to
maintain the threat on G7 with Queen
takes G7 then black inserts 93 with a
queen trade and then Rook AJ continues
to trap the bishop with an equal
position for black
so Rook H3 serves as an idea to prepare
Bishop D3 uh
very uh unorthodox way of Defending such
threat but yeah it's this is chess in
2022 or I guess now 2023 but so yeah
after Rook H3 so yeah black has a couple
of different options here
we thought that uh like Queen A5 was was
one move but not as effective here and
Bishop D7 was also possible but in the
game so we ended up with Bishop D3
castles Bishop H7
uh yeah basically I'm not going to go
super in detail as to the theory or the
analysis behind behind this move I just
want to explain the idea and how such
findings might be replicated in the
future by other people
um yeah the specific theoretical details
uh a I don't remember because it's been
a little while and uh be our
perhaps a bit of a secret so we should
D7 Bishop D3 castles
and then Bishop H7
so black does not want to give the
exchange of course so we see Rook h8
Queen takes G7 and C takes D4 so again
the game is not over or anything like
this so just because we've picked up the
G7 Pawn doesn't mean that there aren't
other aspects of the exposition that are
desirable for example after C takes D4
the White Center is objectively falling
apart
so we see 92
but in this position we end up in a very
good sort of opposite colored Bishop end
game for white so
um
essentially the problem for black is
that the H6 Pawn is going to be a
weakness for the rest of the game and in
the meantime the white pieces are very
good at uh at pressuring the dark
squares and we'll see very quickly that
just because there are no queens does
not mean that there is no attack
so Knight C6 Rook C3 excellent move here
so the key to finding this move Rook C3
is that we want to be improving our
Knight on E2 and the only way to do that
is to go through D4 in this case
so after working f8 Knight D4
so the immediate threat for white is
Knight B5
so uh something like Rook G8 would not
be too great as Knight B5 would be very
uncomfortable for black
so F6 and this makes a lot of sense
since black is going to undermine the E5
pawn and therefore the D6 Square so we
have F6 Bishop F4 but black does not
want to take on E5 since this position
would be very uncomfortable with the
white darts or Bishop being uh
uh being very strong where it is uh YMC
magic says so white basically never
wants to play F4 to keep the pressure on
H6
so it is possible to play F4 in this
type of Pawn structure as well
um but it's it's not yeah I think you're
right it's it's not as uh as effective
here I think white generally speaking is
going to have more luck uh pressing on
the queen side in this type of position
especially given that the B file is open
right so
um okay so yeah we have F6 Bishop for an
F5 but this position continues to be
extremely uncomfortable for black
um
so yeah after King D2 Rook G8 and G3 so
we can see that this Rook on H7 is never
really going to be able to move away
from its defensive post and even if the
position is fine for black which it no
longer really is uh okay so I should I
should explain what I mean by that so
this position back here is considered to
be slightly better for white with a
staying within the drawing range but
it's very difficult for black to play
and indeed after a couple of moves we
end up in a situation where black is
pretty much lost here given that since
the pawn is on F5 now and there is no
more F6 Advance black has very little
counter play whereas the H6 Pawn
continues to be a serious problem and
the queen side situation remains very
precarious for black
so we have King D3 and so white just
needs to improve the position very
slowly Bishop V8 and King D2 yeah at
this point white can sort of mess around
since there's nothing really to be
gained from uh
there's nothing really to be gained from
rushing and hurrying into any exchanges
or anything like this
so we have King d8
and I take C6
the Knight take C6 might look a little
bit strange because of the voluntary
entering of the uh what is it Opposite
color Bishop situation
but since black has played the move
candy in order to escape the pin pontic
C6 is no longer feasible as after Rook
B8 King C7 and Rook B3 black is already
facing the threat of Checkmate and again
no queens not mean no attack
so Bishop takes C6 was played but after
picking up the A7 Pawn this position
should be tactically winning for white
um the problem for black is that again
even though there is opposite colored
Bishops the placement of the pieces is
extremely unfortunate and Black's Pawn
structure is just not well equipped to
deal with this situation
so Rook D7 was played so white wishes to
return the bishop to E3 in order to
continue keep up that pressure on H6
um but in this case Bishop E3 would be
really bad since D4 is not good for
white
so white plays Rook before in order to
avoid this plus The Rook is very well
placed on V4 anyway uh continues to
influence the half open B file and also
can swing to various other squares along
the fourth rank say Rook G7 Bishop E3
so if I can return to H7 of course but
white is going to bring the king to D4
and then Advance the a pawn and this
bishop on C6 will end up finding itself
loose in the long run so
so black side to just make a sacrifice
with D4 and try to pick up the H Pawn
uh my here my friend played a really
excellent move A4
so in the case of Bishop takes A4 now
there is Bishop B6 check
and uh pretty much no matter what black
does the problem is that he's going to
drop the b-pawn and that is not going to
be defensible for
for black the slightest C Pawn is just
not going to be stoppable in the long
run
so we have Rook takes H5
A5 so in this position white is
threatening A6 as the B Pawn is
overloaded having to hold both of these
points at the same time black continues
with King D7 so as to prevent that
um but now the king remains it becomes
very Exposed on the D file so we have
Bishop E3
and Bishop e3s is an excellent move and
that it not only prepares Rook D3 check
but also actually prevents Rook G5 and
thereby preventing Black's work from
re-entering the Civilized part of the
board so we have Rook H1 and Rook D3
check and yeah it's kind of sad but the
black king is now forced to move towards
the king side as king C8 Bishop B6 would
allow a perhaps not a quick Checkmate
after Bishop D7 but definitely not a
desirable situation for black so King E7
Bishop C5 king of seven but now rook d8
and The Rook has succeeded in
penetrating through Black's position uh
there are various threats of rook f8 and
rook h8 and uh Rook C6 Rook C7 with uh
very strong attack in all cases
okay one Bishop B4 so there's no
particular reason for why to go up the a
pawn and white is just simply going to
be playing C3 next and solidifying the
position before uh looking for some
active operations against these weak
Pawns
King G7 Rook D6 you know seven Rook d8
repeating moves to gain time classic
strategy when you are on the offensive
Gene G7 for C8
H5
so H5 uh I'm not really 100 sure why
this move was played I believe it's to
set up some counter play with F4 and G
takes off four H4
um okay yeah that's definitely why it
was played
um but in turn black is actually
weakening the G5 square and thus gives
white an angle to bring the king into G5
so black finally cracks under the
pressure and allows the white king to
infiltrate so after Rook A2
so just to illustrate the strengths of
the strength of White's attack it is
already fully possible for white to play
King F4 and King G5 and the truth is
that black is not far away from getting
checkmated one line that I think is
really cool is F4 King H6 F takes G3 and
uh I don't know about you but I think
this is a pretty cool mate here
um
so yeah King F4 would already be pretty
much launching a decisive attack as
black has no reasonable way of
preventing the king from reaching H6
and thereby uh contributing to this
amazing idea
uh if black plays Bishop yid at some
point uh perhaps after Rook takes F2 uh
not only is it possible for white to
Simply capture the b-pawn and roll the a
pawn
um but yeah Rook E7 is also very strong
here since any move the bishop would
allow a further threats here uh perhaps
in this case where I should start with
King H6 and then uh yeah Rook takes B7
is going to be threatening Rook B8 with
some decisive checkmates
foreign uh instead my friend decided to
start with A6 to deflect The Rook from
the uh second rank it's not particularly
necessary so not best but still winning
for white because after Rook takes A6
King F4 the truth is that black still
continues to suffer from this mating
attack
it's a little bit odd to call it a
mating attack but that is what it is
even though there are again very few
pieces remaining on the board
King G5 F4 so black decides to play F4
in order to temporarily uh
stop the king from going to H6 but
because there is no threat for black
there's nothing wrong with simply
capturing the pawn here
in G5 Rook D7
the white position is is so strong that
I believe it's even winning to capture
on D7 and capture the H Pawn with
connected pass pawns here very soon but
there is no need for such a thing to do
right now so we have Rook C8 King H7 and
Rook f8
so now H5 is simply hanging so Rook D3
displayed
the idea for black here is to again try
to reach the opposite color Bishop
position after Rook F3 since a rook move
would drop the F2 pawn and trade of
Rooks is perhaps still losing for black
but definitely desirable and in for
black in either case as this would be
much more defensible than the
checkmating position with uh Rooks on
board
so we have Rook F7 and then Rook E7 so
white is now putting pressure on E6
we have Rook F3
and now
um so there are a few different options
for white
um
okay so in this position
it is now a white to move and to deliver
the mating attack
um
what is the right way image to do that
um okay I think
so I think White's first move here is
actually fine move King G6 the afterbook
takes F2 uh Rook G7 check King h8 my
friend made a mistake here a very small
miscalculation detail so
in this position uh my friend played the
movie Rook C7 because unfortunately he
missed that after Bishop EA check the
Rook can return to F7 after book C8
black is able to give enough checks so
as to save the bishop on E8
um
it seems to me like the move King H6 is
the most appropriate one I'm
I'm not aware of any way in which black
can avoid a Checkmate in the long term
so for example uh Bishop E8 loses to
Rook E7 and on Bishop F7 is very sad
okay perhaps taking the B7 Pawn is fine
right or perhaps not but why not take
the B7 Pawn sure after Bishop G8 then
the white Bishop comes in and Bishop F6
will be checkmating very soon or winning
the black Rook which in this context is
the same and outside of that white is
going to play Rook V8 and force the same
thing so the position is going to be
losing for black
so after King H6 black is not going to
have a super convincing way of dealing
with the threat of Rook C7 so for
example H4 trying to open up the H file
and get some counter play this way would
allow simply Rook C7 and the white dark
Square Bishop is placed such that black
cannot defend against the Checkmate that
is coming very soon
so unfortunately it is fumbled at the
very end and black seems to achieve a
draw here
I think my friend was pretty rattled
emotionally at this point and failed to
continue to put pressure on black
in this position it's actually fully
possible just take the pawn E6 since
after Bishop F7 King takes S7 Rook takes
C8 E6 is waiting for white as the black
king cannot defend the E6 Pawn
um
black should draw here I believe with uh
Bishop G6 is a way to start although I
don't actually remember
Bishop C6 is the better way to start so
um yeah black should be able to draw
here but definitely King takes E6 is the
best way to try
um so in this position we have a trade
and now in the opposite color Bishop
position black should be able to defend
without too much difficulty as there is
no more a pawn and therefore the black
Bishop on C6 is going to be unassailable
so a bunch of moves are played here but
at the end of the day uh ends up not
really mattering and both players
finally agreed to a draw on move 83. so
yeah what I wanted to bring up here was
mostly how uh we we were able to choose
the move 11 Rook H3 in this position so
11 Rook H3 has an obvious idea it
creates a threat and therefore is much
more practical to be used in human games
uh than some other computer generated
Novelties so it creates an idea and we
understood that this was a pretty likely
position to reach the ones with the
opposite colored Bishops since as black
naturally when you're faced by a novelty
you want to trade some pieces and end up
in a relatively safe position
a relatively safe looking position
especially with opposite color Bishops
but in this particular case this
position is extremely deceptively
difficult for black and therefore
represents a very dangerous place to be
struck with a novelty since the safe
looking option is not so safe and my
friend ended up playing this situation
more or less to uh to Perfection up to
this up to uh
up to a certain point there with uh
with this uh slightly unfortunate
sequence of errors
um in any case uh I think that's that's
probably uh all I have prepared
regarding uh this opening just wanted to
show some examples of a great
preparation and some key ideas and how
these Novelties were achieved tying in
and how those Novelties tie into the
ideas of the opening as a whole
given that they all make use of the dark
squares and create uh direct threats
there
okay
um so yeah I think that's it for today
um thank you so much for watching and I
will see you next time
[Music]